[Music]
look at him
i think the song i enjoy crafting the
most in the documentary is
perfect that's my favorite song i've
done perfect was the first song that i
wrote for
them the album so i think it was just
when i knew that the album was sort of
done
yeah well i think i think i think that
like loads someone like kendrick lamar
um drake's obviously doing very very
well i really like taylor's album ariana
grande just brought out that song god is
a woman which is an amazing bit of pop
music so like every
every week you hear something that
inspires you to
be better i think
i don't i don't really know because i've
only i've only done
two songs with i've never really done
any uh
other studio time but i think you know i
think she's quite a similar writer i
think she writes from her own personal
experiences and tries to make the songs
as honest as possible
[Music]
no no i don't think uh don't i don't
think her cats have been to england
maybe they have i don't know i can't fly
with my cats anywhere because they're
they just don't really they don't really
like moving anywhere they're just home
cats
[Music]
sherry but joey's actually here today
because she's got a couple of weeks off
work um so at the moment my mum and dad
have them
there's an artist called labyrinth he
wrote his uncle jealous
and i love that
[Music]
i think you need a little bit both i
always songwrite while some on tour so i
can have a
i can have a balance
[Music]
uh i think writer's block doesn't exist
if you continually keep writing i think
if you
always write songs um and it doesn't
matter how good or bad they are you just
you just
write them i think the only time i've
experienced anything close to writer's
block is having like a long
time off not writing and then it's kind
of getting back into
the swing of things
so there's a songwriter called max
martin uh who i was with
in sweden recently and he wrote
everybody
for backstreet boys and i went around
his house and he had a taco night on a
friday
and he came up to me with the tacos
singing taco freddie
and i just i sing that from every every
now and then i keep i keep telling him
like
someone like taco bell should like
approach him and use that song as a
campaign can you imagine that as like a
huge taco bell campaign
every friday is taco friday and it's
like
you know two for one tacos at taco bell
you're welcome
[Music]
do you know what i always thought i'd
probably be hufflepuff slytherin's like
pure pure blood and i'm kind of like
mixed between
irish and english and ravenclaw's very
smart gryffindor was like really like
brave
and uh hufflepuff's just kind of the one
that isn't so i guess that'd be
hufflepuff
[Music]
i know what game of thrones fans hope
happened to my character
i'm sure they think my character got
brutally brutally murdered but uh i
think my character
is still out there i think he's chilling
like the cat um yeah it was fun it was
fun being in in
game of thrones but i definitely um i
definitely think they should have killed
me off in the episode i reckon that
probably would have been like the
redemption of people that didn't like it
[Music]
yeah it's always like it's either
goodfellas or cool runnings and i don't
know which one they both do different
things don't they
i think the movie the scene i've seen
the most is goodfellas so probably
goodfellas
[Music]
uh i now view my tattoos as one tattoo
because it's just kind of one
thing so i just like my tattoo
i always loved painting as a kid so i
think i'd probably be
something to do with art yeah something
creative
you have to be prepared for like five to
six years of overnight success
if that makes sense you have to like do
loads of stuff that no one notices at
all
and that's like five or six years
minimum you have to like play gigs that
no one
listens to write songs that everyone
doesn't believe in
and just like just believe in yourself
enough and then just never have a plan b
always think that you are going to
succeed and eventually you are if you if
you wish
success into existence basically and
just believe in yourself and don't
don't after six years be like ah do you
know what i'm just going to go and get a
desk job or something if you want to be
a musician be a musician because you can
always make a living
being a musician so these kittens are
here today through best friends animal
society
and it's kitten season right now so it
means there's loads of kittens that
don't have homes
and if they don't get homes bad things
happen to them
so please adopt cute kittens like these
bestfriends.org
go on it find yourself a kitten you
don't eat that maybe not even get a
kitten maybe get an older cat that needs
a bit of love as well because all cats
need love
you